grammy award-winning band bon jovi
recently released their highly
anticipated new album
[Music]
let's do what you can from the band's
15th studio album
called 2020. rock icon philanthropist
and lead singer jon bon jovi was
inspired
by the pandemic and the black lives
matter movement to write the band's
most topical record so far in the new
song american reckoning bon jovi takes
on racial injustice
after the death of george floyd
america's on fire
there's protests in the street
[Music]
her conscience has been looted
and her soul is under siege
another mother's crying
as history repeats
i can't read
[Music]
such a powerful sign john bon jovi joins
us now john good morning thanks for
being with us
i want to get to the album in just one
second but i know you toured with eddie
van halen and van halen back in 1995.
and i just want to get your thoughts
this morning on the loss of eddie van
halen
well every teenager of my era couldn't
look at an electric guitar and not wish
that they could play like eddie van
halen he was
an innovator of our generation
he'll be remembered forever and uh and
surely missed
the the two songs that we just played
john
uh you originally weren't planning to
put on 2020 the album you were pretty
much done
but but things change what what made you
sit down and write those songs
well we went to nashville to create this
album
in march of 2019 and what i thought
was the record was really in essence the
first batch of songs
i had come up with the title 2020 it
would it had a dual meaning initially
which was clarity and vision i knew
where i was going musically
but also the cuteness and the rightness
of an election year and probably sell a
lot of t-shirts
but as events started to unfold
i continued that writing process and
then pulled the album in light of what
had happened with the shutdown
the covet crisis so if i was going to
claim to have written a topical record i
had to address kovid
and then ultimately the black lives
matter movement and the death of george
floyd so i wrote american reckoning
and then 2020 took on a whole different
meaning as an album title where i was
just bearing witness to history
you wrote american reckoning which is is
such a powerful song
after some feedback from your wife when
she first heard the song what did she
say to you
well you know it was a an exercise that
i've done
many times over the years i'll write a
song
i'll think it's presentable and
the first person i play it for would
typically be my wife
and dorothea walked in and said the
verse is great and that verse that you
hear it as it is
she said it's great she says but the
chorus could use some work
and so i went back to the to the room
shut the door and came back
with the call to action which was to
shine a light and use your voice
and then you will remember me in our
american reckoning
and the process went on because i had to
play it for
friends of mine who would be able to
opine uh
as writers and as members of the
community
uh all the way through the recording
process when i went in the studio and it
was our drummer
tico torres who said to me i still think
you can come up with a better title
as i was scanning the lyric american
reckoning was a line in the third verse
and i utilized that as the title and of
course that is what the song's about
our american reckoning and i thought
that makes it
perfect that's that makes it right thank
you to the lovely dorothea john your own
personal built-in truth teller
i love the words though it's very
powerful to me one lyric says
when did a judge and a jury become a
badge and a knee on these streets
are you worried about criticism that you
may receive or
alienating some of your fans you know
normally people at your stature when
they speak out
people you get hammered and sometimes
then you're judged
you worried about that well
i'd be lying if i said i wasn't but i
can only say this gail
um i bear witness to history throughout
the course of this record
when all of us watch that news segment
how could you not be moved where's the
humanity if you're not moved by what you
saw
with the death of george floyd when he
called out for his mom
now with that said believe me i love
the police i have done so much for
police
and firefighters and emt workers over
the years
but in this instance and in others that
we see daily the
most recent one with jonathan price uh
it happens and i had to write the truth
yeah you also speak the truth i love the
album story of love and lower the flag
two of my favorites
you also reportedly got together with
bruce springsteen two new jersey boys
getting together
his album comes out october 23rd boy
would i love to be a fly on the wall for
that session where you played each
other's music
how'd that go oh it's it's always great
i i've been
blessed to have known him for my entire
adult life
and uh so he came over and heard uh
this record and i was at his home and
heard
his record uh weeks and ago and so
it you know it's it's incredible for me
as a fan
to have had that opportunity throughout
my adult life and
uh and it's touching that you know we're
close enough to sit there and listen to
each other's songs and talk about them
john you you uh you dealt with covet in
a couple of different ways both within
your family and within your band
how serious were those cases and how's
everybody doing
everybody's fine now thank you very much
and for those who still don't believe
that
the covet crisis was real we can tell
you here in new york city this was the
epicenter
and having known more than one
person who is no longer with us as a
result
this was very real and then two members
of my band contracted it and
and were sick for four five six weeks
uh one of my sons contracted a very very
mild case he was sick for
three or four days um so
it's all around us and and you had to
take it seriously
but when i wrote do what you can we were
at one of our jbj soul kitchens where
gail is very familiar and i was watching
dishes one day um early on in the
pandemic
and dorothea snapped a picture of me so
that we could tell the indeed public
that we'd be there in fact we were
we decided to deem ourselves essential
because we remained open so that the
indian population could
john to come in and and we were there
can i recommend
i wrote the song that's good that's good
but i really want people to know about
this
you got to get the latest issue of
people magazine have you seen that
couple on the cover
and then when you see the interior
picture i love john
i love so much the interior picture of
you and your four children
and the shots of you and dorothea
younger because i think what a testament
it is to the two of you
and that the children get to see their
mom and dad back in the day who were
dating in high school who were still
together today i opened and i saw that
picture i'm not kidding
it made my heart do little pity pats and
so i'm curious about
you guys are all quarantining together
how that's going for you all now you
said you're spending more time together
than you have in a long time the older
kids too
everybody was together for the first
month and then the big kids made a break
for it and they said
we'll take our chances we gotta go
[Laughter]
a lot of families got a little too close
john bon jovi
thank you so much for being with us this
morning
new album 2020 and it's a really
powerful one
is on sale now